I'm saying that less than I'm saying  that less than one percent of  pregnancies are in the instances of  grape do you think the majority of men  are out here graping women is that your  opinion on the single person's been  grapes wants to do a statistic yeah yeah  yeah but here's here's just like here's  where your non-happy marriage doesn't  want to exactly they don't want to sit  there in front of them okay okay let's  triple it let's triple it let's triple  it let's triple it it's still only three  percent even if you tripled it I don't  even think it would be that high I don't  think so because but this is all based  on your feelings this is all based on  your feelings there's no facts in it